hey Michael what year were you in the
NBA
program
chair I can't hear you that's okay
probably muted
so are you talking to me Michael Reef
yeah what year were you yeah what what
year
78 you preate me then so glad you're in
the class hope you're enjoying I'm thank
you put the guys stay care
than
so is this the tech
MBA group
so I know Julian email that he Us in the
tech MBA so know Jessica is little group
okay so any Tech questions we have I
will turn to you
right she's also part of the group but
she's trying to distance herself yeah
okay so today we're going to start on
the meat and potatoes part EV valuation
discount rates risk free rates so
today's start of the class test is going
to be about risk free rates even if
you've never run into this issue or
question think from from a common sense
perspective so I want to pick some
somebody in this class who is
Brazilian any Brazilians in here okay
yeah what's your name John John's
Brazilian and he's going to Value
Brazilian company and I'm going to give
him two choices he can value the company
in Brazilian r or in US dollars right
the risk-free rate in Brazil indas and
for the moment we talk about where you
get that number it's a little messier
than getting a risk free rate in dollars
is 7 and a half% the risk- free rate in
US dollars is 2 and a half% so you can
do a dollar valuation or re evaluation
very different risk free rates in which
currency do you think you will get a
higher value for your
company whatever terms you want
ultimately it's a value in the price so
you can do
I'm glad that's that's a slam dunk
because you should get the same right
but you see where you can run into this
question a 7 and a half% risk free rate
the discount rates in re terms are going
to be much higher right if the discount
rate is higher in a discounted cash flow
valuation should the present value be
lower so tell me John what's happening
that's offsetting the effect of the
higher discount
rate higher okay tell me why you say the
same items to the same people and why do
exchange rates
change I'm trying to get you to the core
reason which is
inflation it's inflation inflation is
the driver of risk free rates the driver
exchange rates and if you're consistent
that's something we're going to talk
about today it doesn't matter which
currency you value a company and you
should get the same value and thank God
for that imagine being an equity
research analyst you put had a
recommendation on an Indian company said
buy if you do everything in Indian
rupees sell if you do everything in US
Dollars I can either buy or sell I can't
do both so we talk about the rules you
have to follow and how people fail those
rules and then you get two different
numbers because in most cases in
practice when you switch currencies you
get a different answer so there's
something in the process that you're not
doing
right now you talked about nominal or
real that's a very Brazilian thing thing
to say a very Latin American thing to
say because in most of the world we
think in nominal terms right so when you
get a salary offer from Goldman Sachs
you don't ask nominal or real not but in
Latin America if you got an offer you
might be very interested if it's in
bolevard that you make sure it's in real
terms rather than ninal
terms so when inflation was high in Mar
of Latin America they did one or two
things they did everything in US dollars
so so they didn't have to deal with
inflation in R and pesos or they did
things in real
terms what does real terms mean your
revenues can grow only if you sell more
units the price is going to stay at
constant dollars so your cash flows are
going to be lower in real
terms but then your discount rate also
has to be a real discount rate in the
same inflation you're taking away
inflation is going to be the star of the
show today it's going to keep popping up
and it's a good thing that it keeps
popping up because it reminds us of what
drives interest rates so we're going to
go back to that
core here's a followup
question during the last
decade t- Bond rates were at historic
lowest it was the lowest 10-year t- bond
rate decade in the last
century of course if you watch a lot of
cnvc the reason is very simple right
what kept rates low last the last decade
the FED did did it such a convenient
reason the FED didn't how did it do it
quantitative easing you know qe1 QE2
Titanic whatever else they had to do
essentially the FED did it it is to me
the
most damaging thing that's happened
interest trade discussions is this
belief that the FED sets rates and it's
deeply embedded because we keep getting
told that because you started this year
there a group of people on CNBC talking
about what rates will do for the for the
rest of the you know what they talked
about the FED would raise rates the FED
would lower rates as if the FED controls
and so we're going to dig a Little
Deeper as to why that's not true but
again the conventional wisdom is and
every time the fomc meets the whole
world comes to a standstill
right it's like the movie
conclave they close the doors and you
wait for the smoke to come out say like
a new PP rates are going up maybe
different color smoke red smoke rates
going up Green Smoke rates are going
down Yellow Smoke we're not quite
sure why because we're convinced at the
fomc's rate
setting let me start set the stage for
that discussion remember last September
the fomc Met does anybody remember what
they
did they cut rates by 50 basis points
which for the FED is like going crazy
it's a big cut usually it's 25 years big
cut now I remember the headline the next
day fed low as interest rates I'm sure
people say this is great my mortgage
rate is going to go down my credit card
rate is going to go down your company
the borrowing rate you know what rates
did for the rest of the year the actual
rates that you and I run
into they went up the t- bond rate
actually increased by 80 basis points
between September and December the table
rate went
up mortgage rates went up you're saying
why because the FED sets none of those
rates in fact what's the only
rate that the FED sets fed funds rate
have you ever borrowed at the FED funds
rate other I want you guys to try get
online this evening see if you can
borrow the FED funds rate I can
guarantee it'll be a lost time because
what exactly is the Fed funds rate it's
the uh rate Banks loan to each other
overnight overnight it's an overnight in
that's the only rate the FED sets could
it influence other rates Maybe
if it's
credible credible central banks affect
rates because the signals they send
might tell you something about what's
happening to inflation or the
economy describe the FED as a wizard of
ODS remember the moveie the Wizard of O
the wizard has no powers but where does
the power come from the perception that
the wizard has powers the fed's power
comes from the perception that the FED
actually affects
rates So today we're going to get past
the mystery what is it that causes rates
to change over time why were rates low
in the last decade the Fed was a side
play it was not the lead player in those
RS which brings me to a final question
this is one that I got as repeatedly
over the last
decade during the last few years there
have been at least two maybe three
currencies where the risk-free rate has
actually become negative and that freaks
people out and I don't blame that
when was the last econ class you took
where people talked about negative
interest rates econ is always a positive
rate and all of a sudden you look
around and the push back often came from
anal saying I can't do valuation anymore
and here's why when risk free rates
become negative play through what
happens to your discount rates they all
get really low and if the RIS gets
really low they said the value has to go
through the roof I can't value companies
anymore because everything is blowing
up course is that true though when rates
get negative I mean European companies
must be must have been trading at
infinite values right in the last decade
Euro had a negative risk rate in
September
2019 John what did you say when with the
r that that adjusted for the fact that
rates were high in real that your cash
flows grow at a higher rate in real
right when you live in a negative risk
free rate World ises it sending you some
messages about the future of the economy
in that country and inflation that
country you're probably living in a
deflationary shrinking economy this is
not great news so I gave you the benefit
of giving you low discount rate but then
when you do your cash flows I'm going to
say you got live in the same world you
came up within the discount rate so
we're going to talk about what happens
in negative cre rates it's going to be
okay if you stay internally consistent
Bas like so add like 2% just reduce the
FL NE if they're mature companies you
can have a negative growth if you have
deflation you sell the same number of
units your cash flows are going to be
negative
right the this notion that everything
grows at a positive rate is only in a
valuation textbook are there companies
that shrink out there how come we never
see these companies being valued I ask
appraises when was the last time you
valued a company where re us go down
over time never done
it how is that possible it's because
psychologically I don't think we can
handle it it seems almost inhumane to
give a company negative growth rate so
what do we do replace with a positive
growth rate we paint this nice story and
then we give it this negative of course
things are going to blow up somebody
back there a question Yeah question
about sort of different currencies and
risk-free
rates what about probability of for like
the country Sovereign and we hold off on
that because that's something I think
the question you're asking is how do I
get a risk free rate in Venezuela and
Boulevard great question it's going to
be quite that is probably the worst
possible currency to even try but I want
to set up at least a structure that if
you wanted to try it I'll put you on the
pathway so let's turn back I think we
were on slide eight of your packet
because those are all question oh the
last question that that I kind of
skipped was these people who complain
explained to me about negative risk free
rates and that valuations should blow up
you know what the solution to that was
right if any of you worked in appraisal
and you got your stuff from duffen
Phelps or from croll now for a while
towards the end of the last decade both
t- Bond rates have become low and Euro
they suggested that you
normalize rates I'm good friends with um
the people who wrote that croll and the
and I said guys you're doing serious
damage to valuation by suggesting that
people normalize rates first what's a
normal t-bond
rate what is normal I mean how do we
Define
normal it's average over time over what
time you tell me how old you are I'll
tell you what normal looks like to you
if you say normal t- rate is 6% you've
been in the market way too long you
probably started in the 80s you tell me
a normal rate is probably 5% you
probably start in the ' 90s you tell me
it's 4% you probably started the early
part of the century you tell me it's 3%
2 there are people who say rates look
abnormally
High I don't even have check their birth
certificate to know when they were born
you were probably 25 years old of course
rates look abnormally High because
you've lived in a world with 2% rates
and that's all you know this notion that
normal is some number that we all agree
on is just fuzzy and it's already you're
saying you're opening a door and I'm
going to argue you don't want to open
that door in
valuation so if you remember where we
left off last class we were talking
about valuing equity in a firm and I
suggest two Pathways right what's the
first one if I want value
Equity cash flows to equity discount at
the cost of equity I get a value for
Equity right Leon what's your other way
to Value
Equity I'll start you off you value take
cash flow to the firm you discounted the
cost of capital you value the entire
firm and then you subtract our debt you
get value for Equity so two ways to get
put a number in
equity I want to start on that process
dividends can be a special case it's not
so if you want to use dividends it's
still Equity versus
firm if you worked in valuation you've
probably seen firm valuation a lot more
than Equity valuation and I'll talk
about why we T end up valuing the
business rather than Equity it's a
little more flexible it gives you more
choices you value the firm and then you
have to subtract out debt to get to
Value record and a very very practical
question let's say you valued a business
and you're thinking about what kind of
debt to subtract and I'll give you the
choices you can subtract out the
long-term debt in the
company you can subtract out total debt
in the company you can subtract out
whatever you call debt in your cost
remember this is not the first time
you're encountering debt to get a cost
of capital you to come up with debt to
come up with the the weights you can
subtract out the debt you included in
your cost of
capital or maybe you go to town you're a
conservative analyst that terrifies me
what do you do you want to subtract the
biggest number you can so you subtract
out everything account payable current
liabilities let's take the one item that
shouldn't be on the list let's rule it
out what's one thing that you shouldn't
do don't do d right because again being
conservative is not a virtue in
valuation right I'll give you the most
conservative estimate of value which is
your company's worth nothing okay we've
got that out of the
way let's talk about coming up with
realistic value so it's really between a
b and maybe C is a subset of the first
two you know why I picked the first one
a I've seen investment Banks value
companies and subtract out only
long-term debt only in an investment
banking world do you think that you can
borrow money shortterm and not have to
worry about it what I would suggest as a
remedial exercise for them is they be
for forced to borrow money from a money
lender perhaps with mob
ties for two weeks and then tell the
money lender it's only a two we loan
what are you making such a big deal
about it those broken knees that you
emerge with after that you will it's all
debt right so long-term debt this is an
exercise in fut it's all
debt what you saying what's the
difference between B and C until 20 19
accountants had a blind spot on debt
anybody know what that blind spot was a
big item of debt that they weren't
counting
yes leases were treated as not debt
there's some ownership test that they
did but if you're a retail company like
Walmart could have billions of dollars
in commitments which never struck me as
making sense so for the last 35 years in
my book in my classes in my valuations
I've converted leases to debt when I
compute the cost of capital
now of course it happens on the balance
sheet so when I do cost of capital my
total debt included
leases which actually lowers your cost
of capital a little bit because you have
a higher debt mix which raises your
present value right you're saying this
is good I'm going to put remember I've
got the firm value what do I need to
subtract out I need to subtract our debt
but in my world the debt I subtract out
is the debt with leases in it if you
decide to include something as debt in
your cost of capital you have the
obligation to subtract that debt out
when you get to the last stage otherwise
you end up with these inconsistencies so
if you're looking for the right answer
the closest thing I can get to a right
answer is C we'll talk about some Escape
hatches on that one so let's say you do
this right you value The Firm you
subtract our debt the same debt you had
in cost of capital come up with the
value V you take the same firm you take
cash flows to equity you discount them
at the cost of equity and let's say you
do both right should you get the same
value for the
equity we'd like to right again because
we get if we don't we have all kinds of
side
issues it's actually one of the most
difficult exercises in valuation to go
through to take a real company value the
equity directly value the firm and come
up with the value of equity and have the
two numbers match up because you're
making implicit
assumptions that you don't even think
about
so let's start the process with a very
with a hypothetical example where I made
up the numbers I'll tell you up front
I've cooked the books on this example to
deliver the answer I want which is the
same Equity value and remember we talked
about weekly challenges this week's
weekly challenge I'm going to give you a
challenge where I'm going to take give
you the numbers a very simple company to
Value so don't worry no elaborate Excel
spreadsheets needed and I'm going to ask
you to Value the company's Equity twice
once by take and the numbers are not
going to match up and and I'm going to
say tell me why why they're not matching
up what do I need to do to match them up
get the process started it's going to be
a little confusing right now but that
process has to get started so here's
what I'd like to do I'd like to take a
company I'm going to give you cash flows
to equity that cash flows left over at
debt payments let's say the only debt
payment is interest expenses get a tax
benefit you take that you add the two up
you get the cash flow to the
firm the cost of equity for this firm is
13.625 oddly precise but there's a
reason again I said I made up the
numbers there's a reason I have to be
oddly precise the
company is borrowing 50% of its capital
at a 10% rate pre-tax and it faces a 50%
marginal tax rate so remember if you
borrow money at 10% you have a marginal
tax rate of 50% you're in effect
borrowing money at
5% the market value of equity is
1,073
million the Precision in the numbers
actually should give away implicit
assumption so I want to start thinking
about what it is that's making me it's
always nice to work with nice round
numbers why am I coming up with 1,73 and
the amount of debt is 800 mil so I'm
going to try it both ways first I'm
going to take cash flows to equity and
I'm sorry I somehow lost the that should
be raised the power so when you look at
this this should be raised to the power
two raised so the last numbers 2 3 four
and five should actually be power so
basically I'm raising the power I'm
discounting cash flows to equity at my
cost of equity the present value that I
get is 1 173
million that was
easy compan is perfectly fairly valued
then I'm going to try it by taking the
cash flow to the firm and discounting
the cost of capital remember the cost of
capital is a weighted average of my cost
of equity
13.625 and my after tax cost of De of 5%
my cost of capital is 99.94% I discount
the cash flow of the firm at the cost of
capital the value that I get is 1,873 m
I subtract the debt magic I get
match but I I I told you I've cooked the
books here I've fixed the problem get
the same answer there are assumptions
I'm making here that lead me to the same
answer and that's what the weekly
challenge about digging out what those
assumptions are so for the moment I'm
not going to dig deeper because it does
require that you understand cash flows
equity and cash flows and cost of
capital a little bit more and we'll get
there so the first principle in
valuation is do not mix match cash flows
and discount if you have cash flows
equity for God's sake don't discount
them back at the cost of capital I don't
care how well you estimated the cash
flows you've laid waste to your
valuation if you have cash flows of firm
pre-b cash flows do not discount them
back at the cost of equity the
casualness with which people talk about
the D and the CF terrifies me because
they think if you have a d and a CF you
have a DCF but there are so many
combinations of D and CF that don't work
make sure you got them matched
up because you know exactly what's going
to happen you saw that with the kenot
case right the carand valuation you take
cash flows to equity and discount them
at the cost of capital you're going to
overvalue equity you take cash flows to
firm and discount them at the cost of
equity you're going to undervalue equity
so on this page put a big X on the page
because this is not what you're supposed
to do in a quiz you might be in a hurry
you might end up on this page and start
doing things you shouldn't be doing I've
taken every possible mismatch I can
think of and played through so I said
what if I took cash flow equity and
discount the cost of capital no surprise
I get the kard effect the value of
equity is too high if I take cash flow
of the firm and discount the cost of
equity I get a value of the equity
that's too low because I'm attaching too
higher discount rate to the cash
flows I even looked at the possibility
that if you take cash flows to cash
flows of firm at discount the cost of
equity you don't even know what you're
doing you might forget to subtract out
the debt I've seen it happen in practice
because
it's like a mix of you know fish and
fowl you have no idea where it ends up
know so you end up with a value
that's we spend so much time getting the
cash flows right and getting the
discount rate before you do all of that
stuff start the question what are the
cash flows I'm trying to estimate what's
the discount rate that matches up to
it so let's set the stage for valuation
what I'm going to do in the next few
minutes is show you big pictures of
valuation for the moment don't get
caught up in the details of how I
compute free cash or Equity free cash to
the firm or dividends I wanted to focus
on what I'm trying to do in all of these
models the dividend discon model a free
cash Equity model what I'm doing in
common and where I'm diverging so here's
what you have in any discounted cash
flow model you have expected cash flows
in the future right that cash flows
require a starting point and a growth
rate you have a discount rate for those
cash flows and you have closure you know
what I mean mean by closure you can't
estimate cash flows forever so what do
you do you stop at a point in time you
estimate a number of course it can't be
a random
number we're going to talk about how to
do it right and how you can mangle that
number but that's basically the
structure for every
valuation if you're doing an intrinsic
valuation there's only one way you can
apply closure which is to assume that at
the end of year five or year 10 or year
your cash flows grow at a constant rate
forever what does that buy you it buys
you an infinite Series in mathematics
and 200 years ago mathematicians solve
for the value of that series we stole
that equation we act like we invented it
in valuation but this is the famous
terminal value equation cash flow in
your six which becomes just a equation
you plug numbers into but to do that you
have to assume your cash flows grow at a
constant rate forever let me finish that
thought though
if you're telling me cash flow is grow
at a concentrate forever it has to come
with a cap right what's a cap
with cannot be greater than you're
jumping too far ahead so let's do the
first step it cannot be greater than the
nominal growth rate of the economy in
which you
operate why because if you grow faster
than the economy forever you're going to
become the economy then what right I we
will talk about how you come up with the
normal growth rate in the economy
because who the heck knows what the
growth rate in the economy will be years
from now and there are suggestions I
will make on how to deal with that
estimation question but the core
assumption that you cannot grow fast in
the economy becomes one you have to make
so I'm going to show you the three
variants of discounted cash flow
valuation the dividend disc model the
free cash Equity model and free cash
refer
model
yeah estimate
only because once you get to stable gr
what the what the what's you can
estimate for once you get to mature
growth you can keep going it doesn't
change your value but why create pain
for yourself when you don't have
to so let's talk about the three models
right so you guys are going to do the
dividend discount model you're going to
do the free cash FL Equity model and
this part of the class is going to do
free cash flow The Firm first I ask you
what's your cash flow you give me
dividends your job was easy right you
looked at the actual dividend your job
is to forast those dividends in the
future so how how how are you going to
go about doing that in practice
what do dividends come out of they come
out of income so you're probably going
to start by forecasting income if you're
lazy you might just apply today's payout
ratio why lazy because that will change
as your company's growth decreases so
you're projecting out earnings growth
net income growth and a payout ratio how
long do you have to do it until your
earnings start to grow at a constant
rate forever because then the payout
ratio is fixed so that's your job in
dividend discount but the problem with
the dividend discount model is you're
focused on what companies actually pay
out we know beyond the shadow of a doubt
that companies do not pay out what they
can afford to it's not even
debatable that's a pretty categorical
statement how do I know that with apple
what gives them away so if I ask Apple C
phones I've been paying out everything I
can afford to how do I know he's a
liar look at his cash
balance you got 250 billion in cash how
the heck did it show up on your balance
sheet it's a direct consequence that you
could have paid dividends I'm not saying
you should pay it out I'm just saying
that means that if I focus on the
dividend discount model for Apple I'm
going to undervalue the
company so the free cash Equity model is
just a potential dividend model I say
look I'm not going to look at what Apple
actually pays out I'm going to look at
what they could have paid out sounds
like it's going to be complicated it's
one of the simplest
exercises in valuation is estimating
what they could have paid out because
what can you pay out as a business
whatever's left over over after every
other need has been met right it's right
there on your statement of cash
flows that becomes your free cash Equity
since of focusing on dividends you look
at free cash load Equity you have to
project those free cash load equity in
the future so you're projecting out net
income just like the dividend people but
instead of estimating a payout ratio
you're estimating how much of the net
income you'll have to reinvest back into
the company it's like a free cash FL
Equity version of a payout ratio you
project out free cash FL Equity until
again n income in both these cases
though the cash flows you're discounting
are cash flows to equity so the discount
rate is going to be the cost of equity
so now let's turn to you guys you're
doing a free cash flow to the pre-b cash
flow you're going to pre projecting out
free cash for the firm in the future you
can no longer start with net income why
not pre-b net income don't go together
right what the problem net income it's
after interest expenses you got to climb
the income statement it's going to come
with
consequences usually go to operating
income operating income is earnings
before interest in taxes if there was an
account in the room you probably going
netp Abit is not operating I you know
frankly my world the two are the
same it's operating income you're going
to act like you pay taxes on the
operating income why act because you pay
taxes on taxable income after interest
expense but I'm acting like you have no
interest expenses that's why this is
called an unlevered cash flow you're
acting like you have no debt then you
subtract out reinv investment so to
project out free cash on the firm I have
to project operating income saying
what's a big deal operating net it can
be a big deal and we'll talk about why
the growth rates in the two will almost
never be the same you subtract out the
reinvestment you come up with free cash
flow how long do you have to do it until
your operating income starts to grow at
a rate that's a stable growth rate
sounds familiar right all I'm doing in
all three approaches is picking a cash
flow making sure I get a discount rate
that's consistent that cash flow and
doing it for as long as I need to before
I get to stable
growth I like to think in valuations in
pictures okay so if you looked at my
Invidia valuation I take an Excel
spreadsheet but Excel spreadsheets are
almost mindboggling and bankers do it
deliberately you show a spreadsheet
where do you even start
right so I am exposing myself when I do
pictures because it kind of brings your
focus on what is he assuming that I
don't agree with so it is a risk but I
want you to take that
risk
operating everything is so don't let
this word volatile even enter into the
picture what does that mean they move
around if you don't have a direction on
that just let it go right if you're
volatile and you see a trend that's your
job is to estimate what the trend is you
do all company even a mature Oil Company
are earnings going to be volatile why
cuz o o prices change unless you have
some crystal ball that tells you which
direction they're changing worrying
about oil price volatility is going to
get you nowhere right so don't let
volatility stop it's always going to be
the case in statistics when something
keeps moving around how do you work with
it you average it
out so use statistics to it so here's my
first picture it's a dividend discount
model picture it's really adding nothing
to the previous page but it kind of
highlights what I'm trying to do as
start with existing divs by looking at
net income in the payout ratio and then
I project those numbers out until I get
to stable growth and then I discount
those dividends back at the cost of
equity for the moment we haven't
addressed how you come up with future
payout ratios cost of equity that's what
the rest of the classes for what I get
is a present value I'm done it's the
value of equity in the company with free
cash or Equity models I do something
very similar but I replace dividends
with these potential dividends free cash
Equity I go through the same exercise of
projecting free cash Equity still
focused on that income and I discount
back at the cost of equity I get a value
equity and then I get to free cash to
the firm and I require a mindset shift
first my cash flows are pre-ad cash
flows so when I ask you about growth and
you're valuing the firm I'm not asking
for growth in earnings per
share or growth in net income I'm asking
for growth higher up you're saying why
would they be different as a general
rule As you move up the income statement
your growth rates have to get
a little lower you know why why does a
3% Revenue growth translate into a 5%
operating income growth become a 7% net
income growth and a 9% per share growth
calb let's start with the first one why
would uh why would Revenue growth not
show up as operating income
growth could be like economies scale
operating leverage right fixed costs
right all cost Scala and operating
income and net income what causes those
two numbers to diverge
it's interest expenses another fixed
cause right interest expenses don't grow
so net income will grow and why would
earnings per share especially at us
companies grow at a rate faster than net
income for shares number of shares right
if you do Buy Backs the number of shares
will decrease I see too many people
valuing firms doing firm valuation you
where they get the growth rate by going
to Zach or going to
IBS what do they do they actually take
sside equity research analyst forecast
of growth and they report great resource
but here's the problem what's the metric
that most Sal side Equity reserve and
you ask them about what's a metric that
they that they estimate growth in it's
earnings per share growth you take that
earnings per share growth you make it
your operating income growth you've
already set yourself on the path of
overvaluing your
company not all growth rates are created
equal going to come back and look at
that more carefully but you can see how
I move the way I think about almost
every measure has to change so I get
future free cash of the firm I discount
them back at the cost of capital I value
the operating assets of the
company sounds mysterious right you know
all I valued are those assets whose
income is showing up in my operating
income so let me reframe the question if
I'm buing Apple I take free cash with
the firm discounted the cost of Apple
and I come up with the present value
what have are not counted
yet why not why is Cash not in
there because the interest income from
cash shows up where I told you that
somewhere in this class your accounting
soft tissue is going to come back and
bite you it's it so if your financial
statement everything starts to swim
together I want you to fight through
that and at least look at a few expenses
show up below the operating income line
interest income shows up below the op
which means if I valued Apple I haven't
valued the $200 billion in cash they
have that's not Penny change I've got
added on is there anything else any
other assets that companies might own
whose income doesn't show up as part of
operating
income go ahead
K asss be very careful if I'm JP Morgan
and I own that building on 277 Park
like
unoccupied un vacant which is very rare
right I mean so most real estate is used
for operations I can't add that on
because that'll be double counting but
what happens if you own 5% of another
company that's treated as a minority
holding and the income from those
Holdings show up below the operating
income Line This is a nightmare because
if you have companies with lots of cross
Holdings you now have to bring them in
so what's big deal what if they have
2155 cross Holdings I'll let you de deal
with that in your mind think about the
nightmare that creates I haven't valued
them yet I add them on then I subtract
out debt and
own I call these the loose sense in
valuation the reason is when you take
the cash flow and you discounted the
cost of capital you he a sigh of relief
you say I've done my work and then the
Mischief begins because there's so many
things you can do between that firm
value and Equity value that can get you
into trouble we're going to spend 2 s
just in that space so in terms of
sequence here's what I'd like to
do I want to start by looking at the
process of
valuation so I forgot to ask the
question how many of you have picked a
company
already okay Leon I'm going to make you
my guinea pick so you picked a company
have you started the valuation yet good
this is exactly where I want you to be
so where are you going to startop what
are you going to to start
with but to get the top line you have to
have so you're going to download last
year's income statement and that's
become so much e so much easier than it
used to be right especially if you you
remember to get your Capital IQ account
going in which case you can download
every year of data for the last 10
years I think one of the problems with
having all this data is we don't know
what to do with it we're drowning with
all this data and if you take an
accounting class you compute 200
different ratios and you have no idea
whether you're coming or going after
those ratios so here's what I want you
to focus on when you look at the past
Financial date of your company you're
trying to answer three questions the
first is you're asking how quickly has
this company grown over those 10 years
right it's a pretty simp you're doing
this because you want to frame the
future but you might as well step and
the metric I would like you to focus on
when you think about growth is
revenues not earnings not operating net
income why because can a mature company
grow its income by 15 20% yeah you have
accounting you can have Cost Cuts the
different reasons for growing I want you
to focus on the top line so Leon got
that you would focus on the top line
that's going to answer your growth
question but growth is only a piece of
the puzzle right for that growth to
manifest as cash flows below you have to
first make money so the second question
I'm going to ask you is how profitable
has this company been over the last 10
years and there there are three measures
of of profitability that I want to look
at again I might be stressing your
accounting here but if you go back and
look at a financial statement You' see
all three the first is called the gross
margin Vera what's or Nikita what's a
gross margin what does it
measure so but the problem is in a
county class you look at a cogs first
you say what the heck is a cogs right
what is it measure though in in in Broad
economic terms in business story terms
what is a gross margin
measure you're basically measuring unit
economics right you know what unit
economics is how much money do I make on
the next unit that I sell gross margins
are what's going to give it away so
let's take a software company let's say
you get on the Microsoft website and you
order a copy of or you become an Office
365 subscriber they charge you $69.99 or
$89.99 instantaneously what do you think
happens right after you do it you think
there's a little gnome at the Microsoft
headquarters who running around creating
an extra copy of Office 365 just for you
how much does it cost Microsoft to
create that extra copy nothing take a
look at gross margins for software
companies as Sky High because if you're
a Manufacturing Company you can be the
most amazing Manufacturing Company in
the face of the Earth but to sell a car
what do you first have to do you have to
make the damn thing
right so when you see gross margins for
Tesla of 80% you know that somebody's
making up
crap you've heard of Kathy woods and Arc
if you want to see what happens when
people have lost connection or never
made connections with being in a
business start to these are very smart
people say what's wrong with 80% margins
I've seen other you're right you've seen
other companies but they're not
companies that make cars
if you make 30% gross margins as an
automobile company you're a
hero so look at your gross margins
because you're trying to understand the
unity economics of the business your
company's in because that's going to
frame your
story then you look at operating margins
operating income what does that tell you
this is the economies of scale story
right every Company claims to have
economies of scale but if you truly have
economies of scale what clue are you
looking for in those 10 years is to see
if you have economies of SC Calum if a
company so what are you
going as revenues increas in other words
your costs have to grow at a slower rate
than revenues Uber kept claiming that
economy was scale for the first 11 years
of the existence it was a complete lie
and it was right there in front of us
right the cost kept growing at the same
rate or a higher rate than
revenues so operating margin is going to
tell you something about economies of
scale so when when you grow your company
that'll become the basis for whether you
think the margins can keep improving is
have the economies of scaled run out you
still have it and then you look at net
margin the least informative of the
three
margins what separates operating from
net
margin how much money you've borrowed so
you take Invidia they're almost exactly
the same number why is
that Nvidia has less than 1% debt it's
almost entirely an equity funded company
you take caret the two numbers are going
to be very different right grow margin
again but you're looking at the past and
it's not how profitable you're just
looking at parts of the business model
that are feeding into
profit so how much are you growing how
much are you you know what how
profitable are you have you been and
third you ask how efficiently are you
growing growth is good
right but the good side of growth is
your revenues grow you but there's a bad
side to growth which is to get that
growth what do you have to do
you have to put money back into the
business in what depends on your company
if you're an automobile company you have
to build plant and capacity if you are
Uber what do you have to do acquire
customers if you're a pharmaceutical
company invest in
R&D my definition of reinvestment is far
broader than capex on a statement of
cash flows it's whatever you have to do
to get that growth you saying why do you
care cuz growth can destroy value if if
you invest huge amounts to get growth
that's not that much you grow but you're
destroying value and I'm trying to look
at this company is it a company adding
or destroying value how much is it how
efficiently is it delivering growth what
I'm trying to get you out of is this
mindset of I'm looking at the at the
numbers I'm going to compute ratios
you're looking at past financials to get
an understanding of the business unit
economics economies of scale and where
debt is a burden on the company because
it's going to frame your story going
forward
so I'll give you my definition of free
cash with the V and we'll talk about
each of these items more later on you
start with operating income which comes
from revenues STS operating margin you
act like you pay taxes you're saying why
should I pay
taxes well you know unless you want to
be in jail you have no choice but to
play I mean you might try to minimize
the taxes and you know but there has to
be a tax effect and then you subtract
out reinvestment and in in traditional
know valuation textbooks is defined as
capex minus depreciation net capex
investment in long-term assets and
change in working capital re investment
in short-term assets we're going to
shred those assumptions past what you
see as capex and depreciation and
working capital we're looking to what
you're putting back into the
business shred in what sense what did I
say Uber's biggest reinvestment was
acquiring customers it won't show up as
capex in a statement of cash flows I
will treat it as capex why because I
don't have to follow accounting rules I
I have to look at what drives valuation
and this is how you grow I've got to
bring it in so now you're ready right so
Leon has looked at the how many years of
data do you have in new company five
five years he's looked at the last five
years and he's formed at least a
preliminary sense of how quickly it's
growing it might be a money is it a
money losing company so the margins so
if it's a money losing company there's
no point there is a point right you're
looking to see at least if it's moving
in the right direction if you start at -
73% you're - 91% that's not a good sign
-73 going to minus 35 maybe you can
frame the story better and then you're
also looking at the high Growth Company
what are they
investing so now you're ready to tell
your story I'm going to give you two
Pathways first let's start with the more
General Pathway to value a company to
estimate free cash for the in the future
you have to start with revenues right so
to get future revenues what do you have
to do you have to project out Revenue
growth say can I just use the growth
over the last 10 years you can but pray
and hope that this doesn't work in every
company you do because then I really
don't need you CH GPT could probably do
it right it's completely mechanical the
reason I want you there is you might
look at a company with 30% growth over
the last 10 years and say the stories
changed it's going to grow at only 5%
you have to tell me what why the stories
Chang but you start with Revenue
growth second stop you got to estimate
operating margins going forward Leon has
negative operating margins if he
believes they will stay negative for
ever his job got very simple right he's
got the D valuation he's going to tell
me the equity is worth nothing and I'm
perfectly okay with that but if it's a
company that has promised what do you
expect to happen you expect the margins
to improve and there's a question I'd
like you to answer it's not an easy
question to answer which is once you get
through this pay what will your
operating margin look like what's going
to feed into it the unit economics now
do you see why I I want cuz if you're a
software company and you say my steady
state is going to look like it's
45% that's okay but if you're a
Manufacturing Company 15% might be all
you Aspire for you can look at industry
averages But ultimately it's your choice
to make and then there's a third
question a third link you got you got
revenues you got operating margin that
gives you operating income you now have
to estimate how much you will have to
reinvest to get the growth rate and here
your ambition is actually going to cut
against you do you see what I mean by
that the more you think you can grow the
more you will have to reinvest doesn't
mean it's a bad thing someone ask you
how much will you have to reinvest tied
to your Revenue growth that's all I need
to get the free cash of the firm re so
if you look at my my my base spreadsheet
for valuing companies that I use on
almost every company there's Revenue
growth level there's a margin level
there's a sales to Capital level which
just basically ties your reinvestment
revenues I'm done I've got my free cash
for the firm you're saying warant you
breaking what's the point of breaking it
into more detail what exactly am I going
to bring in unless I have something new
to
add so I get my free cash flow how long
do I have to do it until your company
becomes a mature company say what if
that's 50 years could
happen I never go past
that why not because there aren't
companies out there that don't grow for
more than 10 years but the exceptions
not the rule the median growth period
for us Growth Company for a US company
in the 208th Century in the 21st century
been 3 to 5 years 10 years is already at
the 90th percentile and you know what
I'm asking as an investor I'm saying I'm
going to put you at the 90th percentile
if you can grow longer that's icing on
the cake I want it for me imagine
putting in a 50-year growth period for
inor and finding it fairly valued
congratulations you got the value but
what has to happen for you to break even
it's got to grow for 50 years selling AI
Chips To whom martians maybe that's in
your story but if you make your base
story that this will be the greatest
company in the face of the
Earth that's like signing One S and
saying he's going to hit 75 home runs
and win has a World Series every year
for the next 10 years anything less is
now a negative
surprise that's not a great place to
be and to Discount these you need a cost
to Capital lots of details but let me
set the intuition up for the cost of
capital there are two ways I can raise
money borrowed money or for Equity let's
start with the easy one the cost of Deb
is the rate at which I can borrow money
longterm today I'll talk about the
longterm later on why we make it
longterm so you're a banker you're
lending me money I'm trying to figure
out what interest rate you're charging
so help me out here before you even
embark on that exercise what's the first
thing I have to get out of the way
Brazilian US dollar I have to tell you
in what currency right because it's
going to be very different if I'm boring
so let's say it's an US
dollars so you're lending me money today
what's the absolute lowest rate I can
expect to see on a long-term
borrowing 4.5 4.6 which is what the t-
bond rate
is and if would you lend me money at
that rate if you're a banker and you
went around lending money at 4.5% you're
not going to be a banker for very long
right you're not going to be a bank for
very long why cuz people
default so as long as banking has been
around you can go back to the 1500 and
the RO setting up the banks what do you
do you start with the risk free rate and
you add a spread we can dress the spread
up but it's a spread for covering
defaults a credit spread a default
spread we'll talk about how to estimate
it better but you're trying to estimate
a cost of debt but before I leave the
cost of debt there's one more stop
governments around the
world have made it much better for us to
borrow money than to use equity why
because debt brings a tax benefit
interest expenses tax reduction so if I
borrow money at 8% and I have a 30% tax
rate in effect I'm borrowing money at
5.6% that's the easy part of the capital
equation cost to debt after tax cost to
debt rate at which I can borrow money
longterm today turn to equity and now
I'm going to potentially face a
nightmare you guys are all Equity
investors in my company right you bought
My Equity because you hope to make a
return you know what the cost of equity
is the number you had in your head when
you bought my shares this is the first
of The Nightmare to estimate the cost of
equity I've got to read your months it's
say I can don't worry I cannot if your
mind is wandering you're okay but let's
say I read each of your
minds what's the second problem I'm
going to face
France did you all of you get together
in a bar and agree on a number before
you got no each of you came from your
different places different risk verions
each of you is a different number right
so if you think about a stock like
Invidia how many people own shares in in
I'm not expecting a precise answer a lot
of people with very different numbers
and for 70 years in finance we've
struggled with this how do you come up
with one cost of equity for a company
where there are thousands of people
investing in the company so let's see
how we've resolved this problem you're
not going to like some of the
assumptions we make let's say Ravi owns
a th000
shares and France owns a million shares
whose mind do I care about
more you're done right
let's say France owns a million shares
but he's a Founder SL investor he can't
trade because he gives up control then
but Gabrielle owns a million shares but
he trades those shares who affects
prices
more in corporate finance we call those
investors the marginal investors and you
know what evaluation you have to do in
value company you got to look at look at
risk through their eyes you're saying
but I feel a lot more
risk that's your problem
because that risk was entirely avoidable
right if you wanted to you could have
bought an index fund you chose to not
diversify the market doesn't reward that
kind of risk so when you do cost of
equity you got to act like your black
rock or vanard the two largest
investment in Nvidia are Vanguard and
black
rock they're saying so
what how many what companies does
Vanguard own really the question should
be what companies does Vanguard not own
right
it's a supremely diversified investor so
what what does that mean when they look
at Nvidia the risk they see is the risk
it adds to a portfolio we've just
essentially had finances biggest
breakthrough entire discipline came from
this breakthrough Harry Marco it's in
the 1950s that the risk of a company is
not the risk of it standing alone but
the risk added to a
portfolio when you use a beta whether
you like it or not this assumption is
following you because in C estimating
the cost of Equity we estimate the cost
of equity to that Diversified investor
to get there start with the same risk re
rate we start with the cost of debt with
4.5% the beta will measure on a relative
basis how risky you are relative in what
sense beta is a scaled around one when I
tell you beta of a stock is 1.2 I've
already told you that it's riskier than
average 1.2 times a relative risk
measure and then you multiply the
relative risk measure by the price of
risk in the equity Market say what the
heck is a price of risk in the equity
Market hey when you put your money into
stocks I hope you expect to make more
than five 4.5% why because you can make
4.5% effortlessly right so to get you to
invest in equities I've got to at least
promise you more I might not be able to
deliver it's called the equity risk
premium it's a fancy word for you think
that price of risk changes over time I
we had a twoe period where each being
tested right
first came deep seek then came tariffs
who knows what the next week will bring
this next 15 weeks each of us is going
to find the price of risk changing and
so is every so when the price of risk in
the equity Market changes what happens
stock prices
change we're going to talk about
estimating Equity R scrims and betas but
the cost of equity comes through that
process I a cost of equ in a cost of
debt I take a weighted average based
on Market valuates as opposed to
what let go of your accounting self
because in an accounting statement a
bance sheet that's a shareholders Equity
that's book Equity Let It Go in
valuation it's always market value
weights and those weights can change
over time so if I'm valuing in I can
start with 99% Equity 1% debt but
nothing stops me from changing the debt
ratio which means that your cost of
capital can also change over time in
fact you're probably not going to see me
value a single company where the cost of
capital stays the same over time because
the company story of course it's
got that's the process evaluation and as
you can see the steps the way I'm going
to break them down is I'm going to start
by looking at the past don't give up on
that are some of you going to have more
of a past than others absolutely a valan
Coca-Cola you have a lot of history you
can look at the Levi St lift
example you saying that's unfair my team
member is 85 years of date I have only
three hey it's not it's it's it is what
it is you got to live in the world
you're in three years of data is what
you have learn what you can from the
past obviously you will learn less than
the Coca-Cola person were but your job
is to First estimate risk and disc
contract we're going to start with that
then we're going to move to talking
about future cash flows and this is
where the rubber meets a road because
you have to leave your comfort zones
right you got to talk about the
future and then we're going to talk
about this closure this termin value
number because it comes with a lot lots
of constraints and lots of
misconceptions and then at the end I'm
going to talk about tying up the loose
SS what should you subtract out what do
you do with cash cross
Holdings so let's get the process
starting with the discount rate does the
discount rate matter in a DCF you say of
course it does d in the DCF that said
though it doesn't matter as much as you
think it
does in most valuation one of the things
I think I see that I think is not
productive is how much time people spend
estimating discount rates and how little
time they spent estimating cash flows my
rough estimate is a typical valuation
80% of the time is spent estimating
discount rates 20% of the cost of
capital I'm going to make a general
statement when I've screwed up on
evaluation and I've screwed up on lots
of them it's almost never because I got
the discount rate wrong it's because
I've got the cash flow
wrong we need to shift our Focus from
discount rates to cash flows so I will
talk about discount rates but as a class
goes on I want you to put it in
perspective and when you look at that
discount rate the consistency rules
apply one we've talked about Equity
versus FM make sure you're consistent
the second we've kind of started on
currency you estimated cash flows in
real your discount rate is to be in
realiz pesos got to be pesos dollar it's
got to be in dollars and third if you
choose to do your valuation in real
terms your discount rate also has to be
real so step back to think about a
discount rate you need it of course so
in a discounted cash flow valuation the
discount rate is doing all of the heavy
lifting in terms of C conveying risk
your cash flow doesn't do it's an
expected cash
flow and if you break the discount rate
down you got a risk-free rate in the
currency of your we talk about a cost of
equating you need a relative risk
measure I'm not even going to call it a
beta because then you're already jumping
into capm I don't need it I just need a
measure of relative risk and I'm going
to leave the door open that if you don't
like Bas in the ca maybe there's a
different measure of relative risk that
works for you and need an equity risk
premium now of course if this were a
financial Theory class which it never
has which SP the next 3 weeks talking
about different risk and return models
in finance I don't have the time for
that and it's not the point of the class
but if you think about risk and return
models and finance are all built around
that so before we embark on this process
of thinking about risk and bringing to
discount rates think about uncertainty
in general it's been a subtext for this
class right you look into the future
you're going to feel uncertain what do I
do about it here's what I'd like you to
start with whatever company you pick
Leon's company I'd like him to make
what's called a risk profile start
listing everything you're uncertain
about you know how long that list is
going to be in fact the qu the really
everything in that valuation is
uncertain even your risk free rate you
might find as uncertain if you're doing
a valuation in Russian
rubles and then when you're done with
the list you're going to have like 35
items and you say what the heck am I
going to do and that's when you get
overwhelmed which is one reason most
people don't try to Value companies too
much uncertainty so here's the first
step to dealing with uncertainty in a
more healthy way when I look at
uncertainty I think of it as going into
buckets let's talk about the first
bucket uncertainty can either be
estimation uncertainty or economic
uncertainty just take in
video what's the estimation uncertainty
that maybe the gross margin is off
instead of 74 should be 76 and if I did
more work I could finesse
it maybe the revenues need to be
adjusted for something that was prepaid
that's estimation uncertainty you know
what economic uncertainty is is how will
the AR Market develop what will deep
seek do to the market the reason I
divide it is doing more research
spending more time collecting more data
what which are the two kinds of
uncertainty are you going to be able to
reduce estimation uncertainty economic
uncertainty is economic
uncertainty and here's the bad news 80
to 90% of the uncertainty you face an
evaluation is economic
uncertainty and you know how it's going
to manifest right when you're done with
evaluation especially if you're a
numbers person you're going to feel the
urge only I collected more data if only
I looked up more stuff I will feel more
comfortable you're welcome to try it out
but I'll wager that two days of data
collection later you're going to feel
even less comfortable than you were
because you you know you're just taking
something that doesn't matter in trying
to finesse and that's why I call it the
karmic point in valuation where you said
there are someone certainties I worry
about and some I don't economic
uncertainty I say okay it's that it's
going it's going to affect my valuation
nothing I can do about it second
classification uncertainty can be micro
uncertainty or macro uncertainty micro
uncertainty is uncertainty related to
something the company does its
management does if youing Tesla what are
your micro uncertainties probably send
you to therapist if you thought too long
about it starting with Elon and electric
you know whether they're Tesla 3 the new
Tesla 3 is going so forget about the
Cyber truck you all these things that
are micro but are there you know micro
uncertainties yeah inflation could go up
interest rates could change the economy
could go into recession he's saying why
divide into micro and macro you know
which of these two uncertainties show up
in your discount rate at least in the
traditional Finance view of the word
what do we say about risk that you
building risk that a diversified
investor would find which is risk you
can't can't diversify a away it's just
micro
uncertainties micro uncertainties
average law of large
numbers so you can have a company with
lots of micro uncertainties and a low
discount
rate anybody think of a good example of
company lot of micro uncertainty low
discount
rate is a biotechnology company
risky young farmer company yeah but what
kinds of risk are you thinking
about that a drug would not make it
through the pipeline which is the
quintessential example of a company
specific risk when a VC invest these
young young farmer company uses a 40%
discount rate I have to take a second
look I mean I look at what is that what
exactly you building in there Microbus
is
macro and there's a third group a of
risk where I divide risk into discrete
risk and continuous risk I'll take the
easy half of that continuous risk is
risk that affects you every moment of
every day if you're a US company with
European operations every moment of
every day your value changes why because
every time the exchange rate
changes your cash flows change right but
if you are a US company with operations
in a country with fixed exchange rates
things look really stable until they
don't you've traded off continuous
uncertainty for discrete a devaluation a
revaluation which of these two risks do
you think is easier to bring into
valuation or deal with this business
continuous uncertainty or discrete
uncertainty continuous is far easier in
finance we've studiously avoided
discrete uncertainties so when you talk
about valuation people act like there's
no nationalization risk no failure risk
we can't do that we can't look away from
this so discret try that out take your
company and think about risk and put
them into these
buckets which essentially kind of gives
you the big picture question so when you
look at a company and say it's risky I'm
not going to let you stop there I'm
going to say what kind of risk are you
talking about the reason I ask is not
because I'm inherently curious It's
because I want to figure out it's a risk
that it's going to affect my discount
rate or not second I'm never going to
ask you what would you like as a hurdle
rate you're going to say 15% 18 but you
can't do that you're a market taker when
you enter the public markets I don't
care what you would like to make I'd
like to be able to
fly but I'm not going to jump out of a
window saying I can fly not if I'm
sayane what you like as a hurdle rate is
kind of irrelevant I've seen people
doing these things I used to 15%
discount rate why because I like 15%
discount rates I need to make at least
15% okay I'd like to eat 5,000 calories
and remain the same weight it's not
going to work you can't put an
unrealistic expectation up front and
allow it to and finally the the
diversification effect don't make it any
more mysterious than it
is how does diversification work I it's
a law of large numbers
right basically that when you have
company specific that cut in both
directions that averages are so as we go
through this class we're going to come
back to them but as you as I said if
it's a finance class you can go through
mods I'm going to do a
two-minute review of the evolution of
risk and return model and finance some
of you might remember this in my
corporate finance class the oldest risk
and return model in finance textbooks is
the capital asset pricing
model the risk free rate is a starting
point for every one of these models so
that's not any different but in the
capital asset pricing model everybody
ends up looking like
Vanguard why because there are no
transactions cost and no private
information everybody gets supremely
Diversified and risk is measured with
one number the beta against that market
portfolio amazingly simple model it's St
it staying power tells you how
compelling it is to have a simple model
1964 1978 Steve Ross said y said
multiple source of Market risk why are
we all trying to capture the One beta
see Arbitrage pricing model allows for
multiple Market risk factors in a bait
against each one but the factors
themselves were
unnamed Factor one factor two is a
statistical model which never caught on
why because no compan is going to jump
onto the bandw I'll use Factor 2
model if you put names on the factors
interest rates yield curve GDP growth
you've gone from an Arbitrage pricing
model to a multifactor model and then in
1992 Jee farmer and Ken Fred perhaps the
most widely quoted paper in active
investing and finance said why are we
even trying to build a model why don't
we let the market tell us what's
risky you how will the market they took
5050 years of returns looked at what
kind of companies on high return small
cap companies low pric to book companies
and they said those must be measures of
risk you see why it's a leap of faith
because you're assuming markets must be
right over long the long term I call
these proxy models for risk you've given
up on measuring risk if you're a small
company I say you're
risky it's a bludget but you can see why
people went that
R ultimately in all of these models
though you need a risk-free rate to get
started so I'm going to use the cap I'm
not partly because I'm going to continue
to use it in this class because I think
there are ways in which you can use it
better but if you decide to go with an
Arbitrage or a multiactor model
everything I say about RIS rates with
the cap will carry over there everything
I say about a single B you multiply by
five for an Arbitrage pricing model and
everything I say about Equity risk
premiums you now have multiple risk
premiums the same thing will apply so I
need a risk free rate I need an equity
risk premium and I need a beta which of
these three should be the slam duunk
RIS free rate when I did my MBA it's a
long long long time ago how much time we
spent on the RIS free rate 2
minutes I was told to use the US
Treasury rate as a risk free rate and we
moved on shows you how dollar Centric my
MBA class
was and also how much trust there was
that if you have a US Treasury it must
be
risk-free both are kind of shaky at this
point in time but today you can't pass
is by in 2 minutes because the world has
become
Messier so what I'd like to talk about
is what a risk free rate is and you're
going to find maybe the next discussion
too much on the risk fre rate but I
don't think we have a choice but to
delve it so I'm going to give you what
I'm looking for when I'm looking for a
risk-free rate I want to find an
investment where I know exactly what I'm
going to make
guaranteed pile that away so when you
say I'm going to make 4 % at the end of
the period I come and look at what you
made you're always going to make 4% so
if you think about what you need for
that to be true first The Entity issuing
the security can have no default risk
not even a tiny bit because we have
default risk to call it
risk-free is absurd right second there
can be no reinvestment risk what am I
talking about if you have a 10-year time
Horizon even if you believe the US
Treasury has no default risk is a
one-year T risk free if you're looking
at a 10-year time rizon
tell me why it's not because at the end
of year I have to invest in a table and
two and I don't know at what rates so
onee tble is not risk free if I'm
looking at a 10year time Horizon a
10year t-bond is not risk free if I'm
looking at a oneyear time Horizon
because it's price
risk we just made the water more murky
right because for me to tell you what
the risk free rate even is in US Dollars
the first thing you need to tell me is
over what time Horizon there's no such
thing as a dollar risk free rate that
just floats on its
own so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to talk about three things here
first it's time Horizon matter second
currency clearly plays a role and third
just because you have a government bond
rate doesn't mean you have a risk fre
rate unfortunately much of the world you
told Government Bond rate must be some
of you worked in appraisal work in India
value companies the Indian government
bond rate in rupees becomes your rree
rate but that implicitly assumes that
there's no default risk for a government
when it issues Bonds in the local
currency there's actually a logic that
backs it up right why should governments
at least in theory never have to default
in a loc on a local currency
Bond you print the money right but
here's the fact that works against that
you know that half of all Sovereign
defaults government defaults in the last
50 years have been local currency Bond
default
defaults governments choose to default
even though they could print the money
say why they be stupid enough to do it
when you print money to pay off debt
it's true you didn't default but did you
create another
consequence you have inflation you're
caught between a rock and a hard place
right you want inflation often
hyperinflation or do you want it to fall
and what Latin America has start us and
let's face it everything we know about
Sovereign default Latin America is start
us it's like the Bible of sovereign
default everything that's happened there
is that it's easier to come back from
default than it
is from inflation I went to Brazil for
the first time in 1997 to teach
valuation class to days every question I
was asked was a question about inflation
nobody cared about return on capital or
growth it's why because it was 5 years
after hyperinflation and they were de
PTSD basically everything
inflation it took 15 years before the
Brazilian government could issue 10
bonds and R because nobody would buy R
bonds long term they all at issue bonds
and
dollars this morning I was looking at
I'm going to put a post up on U pricing
you know what the highest p ratio Market
in Latin America is right
now
Argentina in any just word nobody should
ever lend to Argentina ever again right
this country that makes an art form of
default every three or four years but
guess what every every fth year it's
back again it's amazing people almost
have
amnesia the bottom line is just because
you have a government bond rate doesn't
mean you have a risk free rate so I'm
going to present you with a series of
fairly simple questions which I think
can lead us to think about risk- free
rates better let's say you're valuing a
US company in US dollars or any company
in US Dollars and you want a risk free
rate I'm going to give you some choices
for the risk free rate and as I go
through them I want you to cross out the
choices that don't apply because I'm
going to come back and ask you why you
cross them up so I could use a 3-month
table R why
not short a time for what so given what
I'm doing right which is value companies
when you value companies how long you
estimating cash flows no that's not true
I stop after 10 years but what happens
after 10 years cash flows go on forever
so it's really really long time I don't
even know how many zeros there are in
thousands of years but no
forever so too short ter how about a
10year
t-b maybe but a 30-year t-bond should be
better than a 10e tond
right I'll come back and talk about why
I continue because if I purely if I
picking just risk R rates a 30-year Bond
wins over a 10year bond because my cash
flows continue forever you want a really
long-term rate why not a tips rate you
know what a tips rate is it's an
inflation protected t- Bond was about
2.26% when I did this why can't I use
that if I'm valuing a company in US
dollars because the minute you put a
currency on your cash flows you're doing
things in ninal terms because you're
doing things in real terms there's
really no need for a currency the minute
I say US Dollars it's a nominal cash
flow and I can't use a real discount
rate what about the last two the highest
the the the highest of these numbers why
would I do that I'm a conservative
person I'm going to go fine don't even
go
there or the low to the
numbers or some other thing there is of
course an implicit assumption I'm making
you know using any of these numbers
which
is that the US
Treasury has no default risk 20 years
ago people say of course how many times
in the last decade have we dance this
dance of the government might default
this
weekend it's not a financial default
it's a political default actually in the
US because you got this very strange
system of you come up to a debt limit if
Congress doesn't pass no go on with you
you it's a different kind of default but
we've planted the seeds of at least a
possibility and you know where the seeds
have taken ground right ratings agencies
rate companies the US still has a AAA
rating from
Moody but S&P and fit is now below AAA
so we've now opened the door to default
risk we'll have to talk about what to do
if you want to bring in in for the
moment I'm going to keep the t-bond rate
as my risk free rate and dollar but that
could very well
change let's move on step forward
anybody valuing a EUR European company
who you value on on Swiss company right
that's I'm going to cut because Swiss
frank so that'll be easy get a Swiss
rank risk free right who you Val
Juliet okay which is based where okay I
want somebody with the European
company no nobody's doing European you
haven't even thought about European
companies there is a continent called
Europe with a lot of companies if you're
having trouble finding a company you
might want to look there right so
Jessica is going to pick a Spanish
company to Value I'm not pre picking but
let's say you pick a Spanish company to
Value you are doing your valuation in
Euros right why because all your
financials are in Euros might as well
stay with Euros you want a Euro risk
free rate so what did I say we're going
to do going to find a 10year government
B yours I did but I have a bit of a
problem you see what the problem is 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 governments all of
which issu 10year bonds all in euros and
the rates are all
different so Jessica help me out here
which of these rates are you going to
use in your Spanish company
valuation this is the statistical
solution the only problem is what do we
say why are these rates different in the
first place they're all in the same
currency what's the only reason for
differences there's more default risk
right that's the only reason this is
1998 drma bonds and dut these are all
Euro bonds so almost so I'm going to
come back to Jessica the only reason for
the differences is higher default risk
countries like Spain and Portugal and
Italy have higher rates and I don't want
default risk in there what is the rate
that it keeps as a shot of being
risk-free here Jessica
why not because it's German but because
it's the lowest for much for all of the
Euros existence the German Euro bond has
been the lowest rate but it's getting
closer the Netherlands now has a rate
very close because Germany has its own
set of economic problems now and budget
problems so who knows a year from now
and I put this graph up it might be the
Dutch bond that has the lowest rate go
with the lowest Euro bond rate as your
risk cre rate but just saying but I want
to punish my Spanish company for being
Spanish or my Greek company for being
Greek I will give you plenty of chances
to punish your company for being Spanish
or Greek just don't do it in the risk
free rate you value a Russian company in
US Dollars what should use as your risk
free rate the USD bond
rate but it's a Russian company I
know there are two other inputs to come
right you need a beta and you need
Equity risk premium I'll let you punish
your company there don't punish it in
your Base number because then you're
double counting
risk the third example say you're
valuing an Indian company in Indian
Rupees at the start of 2025 the 10year
rupee bond rate you had it has to be
rupees don't use a dollar bond rate or
it has be was 6.8 out wager across India
people are valuing companies was that
that is a risk
creater but you do that you're assuming
that there is no default risk and this
don't take this as a patriotic slight
I'm not talking about India will default
but I'm saying in that number there is
the posibility some of it is for default
and I'm going to help you on that road
so I'm going to cheat and I'm going to
use a very simplistic measure of whether
there's default risk I went to Moody's
and I looked up the Sovereign ratings
for India and if you ever visited that
page every country has two ratings local
currency rating and a foreign currency
rating foreign currency rating is when
borrows in Euros or dollars the local
and I was hoping I was praying I would
see a AAA under the rup under the local
currency rating because they not have
used to 6.82% and blame Moody if
something went wrong what I saw instead
was a B3
rating at the start of 2025 a B3 rated
Bond had a default spread of about
2.18% looks like I made that up and
sometimes I do make up stuff but next
session I'll talk about where I get
those default spreads it's like an
algebra problem right the government
bond rate is 6.82% I'm worried that some
of it is might for default risk and to
the degree that you believe this default
spread number see what the risk free
rate for India is going to
be first let's say get a sense of
direction are you going to add the 2.18%
or subtract out the
2.18% subtract out because you want to
take out the default risk you subtract
out 2.18% the risk-free rate you get in
Indian Rupees is
4.64% you know why I want to do this
because later on you're going to punish
this company by giving it an Indian
Equity risk premium and guess what that
number is going to be high because India
is a risky country and often it's the
same spread that's driving that risk
premium in most Indian company
valuations I think you double count
India country Risk by using the Indian
government bond rate and that's what I'm
trying to push back
against so pleas set up how I think
about spreads because in the next class
we'll go through that this entire
approach requires that come up with that
2.18% right there are three ways you can
get this spread one is if your country
issues Bonds in US Dollars Brazil for
instance issues 10year Bonds in US
dollars at the start of 2025 that number
was
7.75% the Indian government bond rate
was 4.58% I'm sorry the US bond rate was
4.58% that difference
3.17% is the bond market estimate of the
default
risk in Brazil until about 20 years ago
this is the only choice you had you to
find the only problem is there only
about 15 countries in the world that
issue Bonds in B in dollars or Euros you
can't do this we have rupee bonds you
can't do this for India India does not
issue dollar denominated 10year bonds
the government
doesn't 20 years ago New Market opened
up called The Sovereign CDs Market know
that market is just a fancy
way of describing a market where you can
go by insurance against Sovereign
default so let's say you buy an Indian
bond and you want to protect against
default you can go to The Sovereign CDs
Market buy a bond it's a market set rate
at the start of 2025 that number for
Brazil was about
3.23% I actually comput a netted out
number where I take out the US number
from it just to get a set but it's about
2.8 to 3 so basically that's what the
Sovereign CD you why would that number
ever be different than the Government
Bond number it's liquidity trading this
is a much more liquid Market than the
Government Bond is and this you can get
for about 80 countries that's better
than the 15 we had for government bonds
but I still have a problem right there
are about 900 countries where there is
no Sovereign CDs spread and no rating
for those countries I use the lookup
table which is you tell me your
Sovereign
rating I'll tell you what the spread
should be right the 2.18% came from
looking at the B3 rating for India so
you can look at the default spread
so next class when we start we'll talk
about what if the three approaches can
all be used I get three different
numbers which you can for Brazil which
one should I use I'll start with that
come with the next class but I want you
to start thinking about risk free rates
as something that's more than just you
look it up in the Wall Street Journal it
is a lot of worth at least in some
currencies
that